[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
knock it off happy Wednesday America now
when you think of San Francisco what did
you used to think of cable cars
Rice-A-Roni Alcatraz
Carl Malden's nose
yeah you remember him right huh
[Music]
oh man Streets of San Francisco now they
call it Frisco because shoplifters stole
the other letters
you may have heard Nordstrom's closing
both downtown stores due to the
astonishing amount of shoplifting when
asked about Nordstrom folding the White
House said they thought they already
blew that up
one of the things that has been out
there to shut down the pipeline of
Nordstrom one
[Applause]
yeah we dug that up
we dug it up but that could happen to
anyone who Among Us hasn't confused the
pipeline with a department store
I'm sure I've had gas in both
okay to laugh
but yeah another major retail
crime or as Nordstrom put it quote the
Dynamics of the downtown San Francisco
Market have changed dramatically
impacting customer foot traffic to our
stores and our ability to operate
successfully true nothing impacts foot
traffic like those feet hopping over
needles and piles of poop or getting run
over by violent looting nut jobs so let
me translate what that statement really
means for you thanks to Liberal policies
built out of cowardice from spineless
politicians that refused to judge or
punish Street scum's criminal Behavior
once again something that was good has
been ruined may you all die in the next
big earthquake
I added that last part for dramatic
effect
that's why I don't work in PR
Puerto Rico
yeah but you can't sell stuff if
shoplifters already stole it and crime
makes customers stay away so it makes it
kind of tough to run a business and it's
not just Nordstrom 20 stores have closed
in Downtown SF since 2020. Whole Foods
Crate and Barrel Marshalls Office Depot
Saks Banana Republic even the Gap
thankfully Baby Gap stayed open their
onesies fit me perfectly
SF is boarding up so many windows they
better pray Home Depot doesn't close or
they're really screwed
then they'll have to borrow Paul
Pelosi's hammer
[Applause]
time he's a victim of crime and it's all
due to the incompetence and willful
negligence of local leaders you can't
blame the pandemic because the policies
were there first and there's no vaccine
against that despite all the syringes
the downtown Whole Foods opened roughly
a year ago and since then there were 568
emergency calls to police that's almost
as many crimes as turds on the sidewalk
I know because I sent Jesse's assistant
Johnny to count them
he didn't mind the report on uh one
9-1-1 call States man with machete is
back
the caller was immediately arrested for
assuming the attacker's gender
but the key words there is back so this
wasn't his first visit with the machete
and he wasn't there to cut prices
it is Whole Foods other calls detailed
how vagrants threw food attack customers
overdosed on drugs and even tried to
crap on the floor
sounds like fondue night at kudlow's
house
that's why he's always smiling so why
not call the cops well you can try but
they might not be there to pick up the
phone the SF Police Department has lost
more than 330 officers since 2017. I
guess you don't have to defund the
police if they all quit so why do people
think it's okay to just walk out of a
store with an arm full of merch without
paying for it because in places like San
Francisco it is okay the city stopped
enforcing the law years ago a decade ago
even an SF ballot referendum downgraded
any theft of less than 950 bucks from a
felony to a misdemeanor it's like
playing the price is right and you win
if the loot adds up to under a grand at
least it's forcing people to do math
something the schools no longer do
and security guards there are now told
not to stop shoplifters so what are they
securing exactly a low paying job where
they get to watch stepmom porn on their
phones that sounds pretty good
and the one thing all these cities have
in common they're run by the left AKA
America hating scum to progressives
Prosecuting crime is racist it
persecutes the oppressed a smash and
grab is really justifiable
redistribution and who cares if the
law-abiding are the ones you get hurt
that's for their white privilege even if
they're you know Asian Black Or Hispanic
but hey you can't pick an ideology of
chaos and then expect order we try to
point this out to them and they just
laughed and now the Democrats are paying
for it in their own cities and of course
they'll blame the system and not
themselves meanwhile Frisco has spent
over 400 million bucks on a net to keep
people from committing suicide off the
Golden Gate Bridge
if only there were a net for the city
itself
[Applause]
tonight's guest she made a pasta look
like a chump when she defended president
Trump outnumbered co-host and author of
the new book Serenity in the storm Haley
mcadamia
foreign
gasping for air cause he likes to choke
people hosts of the Harlan Highway
s on YouTube
Berlin Williams
in high school she was voted most likely
to slip through a storm train Fox News
contributor captain
and he files his nails with a belt
sander my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
oh
so Harland yeah how's life pretty good
it's my favorite cereal
[Applause]
let me ask you how's count chocula you
never wake him up when I go to work
holy Frankenberry
so you're actually Pro shoplifting
aren't you because you steal a lot of
women's heart exactly
at the hospital yeah
you know what they should do though what
if they were smart the 99-Cent Store
Corporation yes should move into Frisco
and just open stores and all these
places that leave right yeah because no
one's going to steal from that place
they probably have people bringing crap
into that store
that is so true that is so true and it's
kind of a great method like if you don't
like your neighbors or if you don't like
a store like a Radio Shack or you don't
like the Dairy Queen down the street and
all these kind of vagrants are robbing
everything just go to your neighbor's
house and throw donuts and crack on
their welcome mat and they'll be gone
you know you can just get rid of people
you don't like do you um what do you
live in Southern California yeah yeah
right in Hollywood man oh have you ever
been a victim of a crime uh yes yes I I
have I had my uh car stolen it's a Prius
and uh it took about uh eight months to
get it stolen but they finally did
[Applause]
[Laughter]
never forget what
all right Kaylee will you say what do
are we going to see this in other cities
everybody all these businesses fleeing
it feels like it's just it's over of
course
um look San Francisco you remember I'm
sure you covered it because you cover
all the hard-hitting news here that is
true on Gutfeld uh November of 2021 80
people ran into a Nordstrom right
outside of San Francisco in ransacked
Walnut Creek yeah yes and it happened at
the Louis Vuitton happened at the
Bloomingdale's happened at the Walgreens
well what do you think was going to
happen these places are not going to
lose money but this doesn't happen in a
vacuum this is an outgrowth of a man
named Chessa Boudin who is a district
attorney who in a city that is 86
Democrat voted him out of office almost
60 to 40. and recall elections have a
point zero three percent chance of
success so is this San Francisco waking
up I mean I'm not Pollyanna here like I
tend to be naive for the most part I I
don't think though that San Francisco is
changing but gosh I hope so uh because
this city who's going to be left in it
Kaylee
using strong language like gosh
it is um thank you for saying so yeah
it's offense you know this is actually a
family show not like a filthy stuff
you're doing outnumbered my apologies by
the way by daytime television
congratulations on the new book thank
you
thank you
Serenity in the storm I needed it with
old gem Acosta yeah he was my storm yes
yeah ooh that sounds like the beginning
of a romantic comedy
all right I'll stop now so cat
um could these cities make a comeback
well okay let me ask you this you're
Detroit did Detroit ever really come
back or is it kind of stuck in a spot
and is that what's going to happen here
they're all going to go down and they're
going to end up all like Detroit where
there's nobody there but maybe a few hit
bars
okay
downtown of Detroit is a
me okay it's so much fun you can have a
great time in the downtown of Detroit
you just don't go to the abandoned
houses areas uh where am I going to get
my drugs well if that's what you're
looking for then do go there
um but that's what I think is so amazing
in the bad way about San Francisco is
that this is like like downtown stuff
that's that bad yeah so I know Detroit's
everybody's punch line but people who go
there know that the downtown is actually
you can have a very nice time you can
have very great food you can go to a
baseball game you can have a wonderful
stay so light out in the summer I would
love to summer in Detroit quite honestly
um but also in San Francisco I think
another thing we're maybe missing is
also the pandemic right right for a very
long time one of the only markets that
was open was the black market so it's no
wonder you don't need to introduce
racism but that's the one flourishing no
I'm being I mean San Francisco lost more
residents in the first year of the
pandemic than any other city so they
made like legitimate businesses illegal
for a very long time so and then there's
all this other stuff going on that when
they really were struggling to even
begin with because of what they did in
the panda make and anyway Detroit say
nice things about Detroit that's what my
mom always said to me and she's dead so
don't disrespect her okay
you know you're right though because
Market Street where uh wet the Westfield
uh the Westfield mall is where Nordstrom
is is the like the main drag of San
Francisco and it's a mess Tyrus what did
you get from this story The monologue
I'm still stuck on your very specific
porn request of stepmoms
um
it is the number one the number one porn
on porn you have a ratings thing that
just pops up Let everyone knows where
the numbers are at you know oh man
stepsisters are in trouble
no tell me about this uh kill me yes a
little backpack yeah this backpack isn't
just full of paper no I mean listen uh
yeah
listen ever since we lost Afghanistan
you know we've just been going through a
replacement in San Francisco is going to
be a new Afghanistan so it's going to be
fine yeah uh be a place where you can
show the kids what happens when you give
up right you know or do I'm dead I need
to drop you off here and you can live
out here for a while and figure it out
or you're going to go back and get your
schoolwork done so it's going to be a
great place to show pictures
your parents didn't do that they didn't
take you to an abandoned house and be
like good luck no oh you want to come
home yeah you're gonna do your
schoolwork yeah that's what San
Francisco's gonna be yeah and here's the
96 The Haunted House
amnesty City that everyone got out of
yeah and it's literally just the place
where zombies walk and
people use the restroom good news is
they didn't go all in on that new toilet
yes so we can put that somewhere else
but this is what it's a nice amnesty
City so maybe we could just send more
people that way and just leave them over
there because it's gone you know what
you're about you remind me of when you
used to go to the county fair and in the
in the sideshow they'd have that drug
the drugged out guy yeah this is what
happens when you do drugs so people can
actually drive through SF just go this
is what happens I would probably fly
over yeah I would fly over to just kind
of lean your kid out to the window do
you want to go there
taking the smell yeah that's human Feast
it's not an orange tree Sun that's a
crack tree and that person's getting
robbed you want to go all right so we
can make something positive out of it
that's good all right we gotta move on
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else